(upbeat music)
- My name is Mike Perry,
I've been with Broad
City since the beginning,
drawing crazy typography and seeing
what kind of animation explosions
I can make for the show.
- He also has kind of
become our visual brand.
- When I think about mushrooms,
it fills you with warmth and positivity
- We were thinking about
the texture of tripping,
the experience of what
it feels like to trip.
(ethereal music)
- [Mike] So the first thing
that popped into my head
was them walking through
this magenta, pink canyon
with just really warm, glowing light.
That was kind of like, "Okay, this is what
"it's gonna look like."
- That's comic book shit!
- Even in the B-roll animations,
there's like, there's a guy
skateboarding along the street,
but it's like pancakes.
- Yeah, he's on a pad of butter,
you know, skating on a pancake.
- You know, Abbi and Ilana,
they communicate with everybody.
"We trust you, we believe in you,
"do you work."
And that's a rare, creative relationship
and it's pretty damn special.
- Is it weird my nipples are sore?
- No that is perfectly normal.
Mine are bleeding.
(cat screeching)
I really think that watching this episode,
you really feel like you're with the girls
tripping with them, increasing the trip,
decreasing and then like,
doing the stupid thing
of adding weed too early.
- It's like, it's just sorta li-
No, it's just--
- Cool!
- Yes!
- Something about our dynamic feels
it needs to be captured!
- Well, people are doing
some cool stuff online.
- What, like a web series?
(hip hop music)